Formula 1 and it's under Liberty Media
are making their biggest bet today.
Going all in on Las Vegas after 40
years, F1 will return right here to Sin
City.
Racing cars down the strip at 200 miles
an hour.
Why Vegas?
Every major sport seems to be coming
here right now, whether it's the NFL,
the NHL, the WNBA or the UFC.
What you've seen is the evolution of a
town to really embrace a wider group of
travelers and visitors.
It's no longer a place where you just go
spend the weekend and you know what
happens?
Vegas stays in Vegas.
It's now a place where you actually want
to go.
It's a destination and give him a lot of
credit for transforming this town.
It wasn't until recently that we at
liberal media had the opportunity to
really take Formula One to the next
level in the United States through the
explosion of popularity from Netflix as
well as just Americans begin to embrace
the sport more and more younger
demographic and more female demographic.
The timing was absolutely right.
F1 is the hottest sport in America right
now.
Las Vegas will join Miami and Austin as
the third U.S.
based Grand Prix.
Vegas is tailor made for this sort of
event.
There are one hundred and fifty thousand
hotel rooms within walking distance of
the track.
That may mean that Vegas soon becomes
one of the most important dates on the
F1 calendar.